you've got folks that I'm sure you love
working opposite of and then they gotta
die at the end of the season yeah it
sucks sometimes I loved Billy I loved
acre Montgomery he was killed off in
season three I'm in the same thing with
Papa and this season is there one person
or character in particular you hope they
bring back for the final season
Papa I know it can get a little
uncomfortable because you can't say too
much but maybe you can well I really
don't know I mean people say like oh you
can't say too much like don't spoil it's
fine I'm like oh no I wish I could spoil
it first because I don't know anything
because they know that I talk to people
like you and I know that I'm gonna I'm
gonna spill the Deeds one thing Millie
does have Insight too her new Netflix
movie anola homes 2 out now because
she's not just the star she's a producer
Millie is fantastic she makes various
due to decisions and choices on set and
it's wonderful to see Millie is Inola
homes the little sister of Sherlock
Holmes played by Henry Cavill why are
you here is it my case CRM both
seems our cases are connected Enola
herself is becoming quite the
investigator so Millie how do you think
you would fare as a detective in real
life would you have what it takes oh 100
I'm really good at getting into people I
know every every detail of everyone
could I be a good detective probably not
thank you
foreign